[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de América Latina
y el mundo de ahora en adelante los
youtubers y creadores de contenido en El
Salvador tendrán permitido realizar una
cobertura de lo que sucede en el
congreso una decisión con la que según
el presidente de legislativo Ernesto
Castro se pretende defender la libertad
de expresión para el gremio de
periodistas la critica asegurando que el
oficialismo trata de amplificar su red
de propaganda y denuncian la
criminalización del oficio periodístico
empezamos
el balcón de prensa en el congreso de El
Salvador podría estar más lleno que de
costumbre los llamados youtubers y
creadores de contenido ya podrán
ingresar allí en calidad de reporteros
para informar a sus audiencias lo que
sucede en las plenarias de legislativo
al menos ese es el objetivo de los
legisladores salvadoreños durante su
primera visita al recinto Fueron
aplaudidos por parte de los congresistas
según el diputado presidente Ernesto
Castro La medida pretende acabar con el
monopolio de información que según él
existe en el país para tener más
claridad sobre este proceso contactamos
a varios diputados quienes a través de
sus redes sociales se han mostrado a
favor de esta medida pero no obtuvimos
ninguna respuesta aquí un fragmento de
lo que dijo el presidente de la asamblea
legislativa
el derecho a informarse y a informar no
es potestad
de unas empresas mediáticas Yo sé que
hay mucha gente que está que no está de
acuerdo con esta decisión porque al
final están perdiendo ese monopolio
que siempre han tenido
aquí seguramente los que más pierden son
esos mercenarios que han dado
vendiéndose con uno y con otro ahora qué
tipo de creadores de contenido pueden
acreditarse Pues de acuerdo con esta
imagen publicada por la cuenta de la
asamblea legislativa en Twitter basta
con llegar allí y demostrar que se es un
creador de contenido la convocatoria no
hace mención a Qué tipo de creadores
pueden aplicar por lo que se presume que
cualquiera puede acreditarse Incluso si
no maneja temas de política el documento
hace énfasis en que podrán tener el
mismo acceso que tienen comunicadores y
periodistas por lo que el presidente de
legislativo les hizo la siguiente
petición escuchemos
que sean imparciales
la comunicación no puede tener ideología
Como lo hicieron en el pasado
nuestro corresponsal en El Salvador
contactó a varios de los creadores de
contenido que asistieron a legislativo
para conocer su experiencia pero solo
obtuvo respuesta de uno que al final
decidió no hablar para France 24 desde
nuestra redacción también nos
comunicamos con ellos pero tampoco
recibimos respuesta decidimos echar un
vistazo al tipo de contenido que algunos
de ellos publican Y eso nos encontramos
paradójicamente algunos no cumplen con
la imparcialidad que está solicitando el
presidente del Congreso Allen nilson
Castro por ejemplo quien cuenta con más
de 25 mil suscriptores en YouTube se le
ven su foto de perfil posando junto al
presidente nayib bukele la cuenta
llamada El poder del pueblo salvadoreño
administrada por el youtuber Roberto
Silva muestra abiertamente su apoyo al
mandatario Esta es precisamente una de
las preocupaciones del gremio de
periodistas de El Salvador quienes
señalan que estos youtubers podrían ser
utilizados por el oficialismo como una
máquina para amplificar su propaganda
Vladimir Chamorro corresponsal de France
24 en El Salvador conversó con Karen
Moreno periodista de la revista factum
quien insistió en la necesidad de saber
contrastar Fuentes y verificar
información a la hora de cubrir Fuentes
como el congreso
prácticamente bueno generalmente se
dedican a cortar y pegar información a
replicar entonces la población pierde
Porque
los funcionarios públicos le han dado
tanta tanto espacio a estos personajes
que en realidad no van a tratar la
información de manera apropiada porque
no van a aplicar ese método entonces las
personas no pueden tener certeza de lo
que están diciendo es cierto yo creo que
las personas tienen derecho a elaborar
contenidos y tener las preferencias
políticas que ellos consideren mejores
tienen todo el derecho del mundo
el problema como repito es cuando emiten
contenidos
en los que no aclaran O no especifican
cuando están opinando y cuando están
dando información certera a la población
los periodistas también denuncian que el
oficialismo ha criminalizado su
profesión Karen Moreno describió Cómo ha
sido la relación entre legislativo y los
periodistas
durante las coberturas en la asamblea
legislativa hay un ambiente muy hostil
porque los periodistas
están siendo siempre vigilados siempre
están súper pendientes de Hacia dónde se
están se están moviendo
los diputados no responden a preguntas
de los periodistas son muy cerrados y
ahí podemos ver un gran contraste con lo
que ha ocurrido recientemente que
recibieron con aplausos a youtubers a
blog entonces ahí puedes ver un gran
contraste entre Cómo está la posición
hacia los periodistas y hace este tipo
de personas que en realidad no
cuestionan al poder o sea mantienen una
narrativa alineada y solo replican
mensajes hasta aquí este episodio de
revista digital recuerde que si quieres
repetir esta u otra misión de nuestro
programa lo puede hacer A través de
nuestra página web triple W punto com
[Música]